it's 7:00 p.m.
leung kwan-yuen another long day at work
he does odd jobs around construction
sites arriving home the first thing he
does is write down the hours he worked
you go auntie that I must not forget any
deadline the boss does not volunteer any
money again learn his children wife and
mother-in-law have lived for four years
in a fifteen square meter apartment in
the working-class neighborhood of
Kowloon by Hong Kong standards the rent
of 500 euros a month is cheap see Salah
you don't know there's not much room but
for people like us it's quite large
father the building has been sold and
the new owner wants to double the rent
if the tenants can't pay they have to
move out you see since I wore thunder I
am very upset where should I find so
much money
hey real estate prices in Hong Kong keep
climbing what the family could rent for
500 euros now is just a small part of an
apartment one way to spends half of a
wages on rent this is where I sit when I
eat
there's no room even for a stool Wong
doesn't earn much money as a cleaning
lady and the rents are always rising the
authorities are emptying more and more
old buildings often to make way for
redevelopment Wong had a larger room
until a year ago then landlord told her
to leave okay uncle
he gave me two weeks notice but I had to
keep going to work after work I brought
my things over I had to carry my bad
piece by piece
the housing crisis in Hong Kong is
nothing new for decades it has struggled
to house its people there are not enough
apartments the poor are the hardest hit
many thousands live in tiny wire cages
and there's little perspective of change
Hong Kong remains one of the most
expensive housing markets in the world
and the prices for substandard housing
are rising at almost the double rate of
other homes and that's although the lung
family qualify for public housing
officially they're titled two one within
three years of applying but they have
been waiting for a at least mr. Leung
has an appointment at the housing
department juji juji pas je I am a bit
nervous I hope they will really offer
something I hope it goes fast it would
be such a relief
jamort out on the family are hoping to
have more space at a lower price and
greater security they don't want to be
at the mercy of a private landlord
anymore can give notice at any moment